Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Abracadabra, it was a magic trick.
I'm actually here.
If I sound, guys, dragons.
If I sound dead, I'm dead inside.
It's because I am.
For those who are new here.
Every time it's, every time it is...
Oh, it's 12.30 stream.
I am actually not alive for a while.
So, give me a sec.
I was debating.
I was debating if I should have like...
If I drink some gamer subs today.
But like, I ran out of like...
Water, like water.
Bottled water.
So like, and like...
It sucks because like...
There's like construction nearby.
So like, it's hard to get stuff delivered.
Like get groceries delivered.
Right now.
So I have to like...
I don't want to walk to...
I don't want to walk to a grocery store.
And carry back lots of water.
Um, I don't...
Guys, okay, like, it's like PTSD.
But I don't trust tap water.
No matter where I live.
Because like, my parents instilled the whole...
Never drink tap water.
You'll fucking die.
Like...
So...
So like, I...
I don't drink tap water.
And um...
Um, I...
I boil water now.
I do have a kettle, so I boil water.
And uh, the thing is...
Gamersubs...
I like to drink cold Gamersubs water.
So like, you know, when you mix Gamersubs with water together...
It doesn't taste very well.
Especially because it's a powdered drink.
It tastes very well when it's hot.
So like, this morning...
I boiled water yesterday.
And then, so I was like, yeah, tomorrow...
Tomorrow, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking use that water...
When it cools down.
To um...
To make some Gamersubs stuff.
So...
So I'm not tired as fuck today.
Um, and then I woke up.
And then I boiled the water again.
Because I forgot!
I forgot!
I forgot the plan!
I was just like, alright.
I woke up and I was like, oh shit.
I should make some hot water.
This water's cold now.
Oh!
So like...
Now I don't get water.
I still have some of my water from yesterday.
Some water I had yesterday.
Right now in my tumbler.
Um, but...
Um, it has a tea bag in it.
So I can't mix that with Gamersubs.
Because I'm afraid...
I'm scared of what...
I'm scared of what will happen to me if I do that.
Because I don't think that's healthy.
If I mix tea caffeine with Gamersubs caffeine.
So like...
I'm afraid of my heart.
Uh...
That's a...
Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Careful, Doki.
There are chemicals in the water that's turning the VTubers straight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, anyway.
It's like how people would mix like...
No, I did that before.
Okay, so I talked about this story before.
But, oh my god.
I even talk so slow because my brain is so tired.
Um, I got seven hours of sleep.
But I think I woke up at a bad REM cycle.
Uh, anyway.
So, when I was in university.
Um, I was...
I...
I did not care about my health.
In a way where like...
I have exam tomorrow.
Um, oh fuck.
I gotta cram...
60% of the information.
Right now.
And then I would mix...
This...
Five hour energy drinks.
The five...
I would just drink the five hour energy.
The little tiny ones.
The five hour energy.
Plus...
Um, plus a...
Um...
A one shot...
One shot espresso cans.
And...
A...
Like a rockstar energy drink.
Just so I could like survive.
Like I would like not sleep.
So I could pull an all nighter.
And um...
Yeah, no.
I don't know how.
And then like after...
Like after, you know, the exams were over.
I cried.
Because I was...
I was just like...
And I also did that because...
I had to rewrite a paper.
I had to do that.
Because I was due tomorrow.
And then, um...
I also drank a five hour energy drink.
And also a rockstar.
Because like...
I would drink the five hour energy drink.
And I would be like, I'm so tired.
So now I would chug a rockstar.
Because I had to stay awake to rewrite my entire paper within a day.
Because I would...
I hired like...
I would not hire.
But like, um...
I had like a...
A professor.
From another university.
That would read my paper.
And tell me if it's good or not.
And like, she would edit it and stuff.
Like, she would edit it and proofread it for me.
Because I was that...
I was that...
I was that fucking...
Studious.
That really wanted a really good grade.
So then, you know, when you hire like...
Peer review...
Peer reviewers.
To read your paper to make sure it's a good paper.
Um...
The professor...
Uh, came back.
And was like, this is a really bad paper.
LAUGHS LAUGHS LAUGHS I was like, what do I do?
She was like...
This is not a good paper.
Like, you gotta change half of this.
And then, I was like...
What?
LAUGHS I was just like, what?
No, she would do really well for other stuff.
Like, I really liked her.
Because she actually helped me get really good grades.
But then, this was the first time she was like...
No, this paper is really bad.
You gotta rewrite half of this.
And I was just like, what?
But it's due tomorrow.
It's due tomorrow.
And she was like, well, obviously.
She was like, I don't have time to read this.
Reread your edits at the end of the year.
Um...
It's due tomorrow.
But you gotta change this and that and that.
And I was just like...
I can't sleep.
This paper took me...
One month to write.
And now I have to rewrite this entire thing.
Within a day.
Rewrite half of this in a day.
So...
Yeah, so I chugged down a five hour energy.
And then a rockstar energy drink.
And I was just like...
And then in the middle of writing this...
I had a breakdown.
Because, you know...
I mixed those two drinks together.
I was so fucking tired.
I was just like...
Guys, AI did not exist back then.
When I was in university.
These kids have it so good right now.
And so I was just like...
So I had like a...
A mini breakdown.
While I was like...
In one of those hours.
Because I was so fucking done.
Um...
No, they shouldn't use it.
Yeah, but like...
They're not gonna stop.
University students will always take the easiest way out.
If they can.
Because I would know.
Because I was a university student.
If I knew...
If I had chat GPT.
I wouldn't use it to copy it.
I would use it for research.
Just to start the research.
And now I use Google Scholar.
Just to figure out where to go.
But a lot of people just copy and paste.
So now like professors now...
Professors now are like...
Being trained...
To how to spot AI.
Uh...
So...
Um...
It's actually really weird.
Because professors are not trained to grade papers anymore.
They're trained to like...
Figure out if this paper is written by AI or not.
Which I don't know.
I just think that's like...
It's just so fucking weird.
That that's what their whole job is now.
Just to be like...
Did this person use AI?
Um...
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gamersubs used vitamin B12 for it's big energy boost.
Which passes right through you harmlessly.
And excess to Gamersub tea elixir won't destroy you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so...
I could use my tea to mix it with Gamersubs.
But then would it taste...
I'm fucked up with that taste though.
Because my tea bag is like...
Honey lemon flavor for my throat.
Hmm...
So like...
I have no idea.
I have no idea if it's gonna...
Taste wise, it might be fucked up too.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I don't know why.
Past Doki was like...
Don't worry guys.
Next week Doki is gonna finish this game.
Did it this week.
I'm gonna finish this game next week.
And then today is...
Today is next week Doki.
And then I looked at...
How much I had to do left.
And okay, I'm gonna look at it again.
I just remember when I first looked at it.
I was just like...
Wait, that's a lot more than I thought.
Like...
I was like, wait a minute.
Oh my god, wait a minute.
I thought...
I thought I had like...
Almost...
I was almost done.
Alright, where am I?
Okay, so let's see.
I am at the labyrinth, right?
I'm at the labyrinth now.
So...
Am I at the labyrinth?
Or am I at a prison?
No, I'm in the labyrinth.
I just started the labyrinth.
Okay, I'm in the labyrinth.
This guy...
Okay, I have...
9, 10, 1, 2, 3...
Okay, this guy finished this game in 3 hours.
That would be like 5...
That would be 5 or 6 hours for me.
So like...
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay.
6 hours, alright.
Here we go.
Sorry guys, my brain is still waking up right now.
At the moment, so...
I'm like super fatigued too.
Oh my god, also...
That update, Doki Emerdoja update.
Um, it's a little sad update.
Because like...
Okay, now you guys are like...
NO, WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM?!
Okay, no, it was more so like...
I was walking him yesterday and it was raining.
So there's like puddles and everything.
And then like...
So like, you know, there's cars driving by.
So I was like, I was like...
Doki, no.
Because he was like, I WANNA CROSS THE ROAD!
I WANNA CROSS THE ROAD!
And I was like, no, there's a giant puddle, come back.
But he didn't care and I kept pulling him.
And I was like, NO!
I WANNA CROSS THE ROAD!
I WANNA BE CLOSER TO THE ROAD!
And the car fucking...
And then, you know like...
In movies where like...
Water would just like splash on the road and stuff.
It would just happen in movies and it was like a giant water splash.
Well, it wasn't in the movies.
But it actually happened.
And so like, he was like drenched in water.
And he was like...
And he backed off instantly.
But then obviously, he still got drenched.
But then he looked at me.
And he was like, you let this happen?
I was like, what the fuck do you mean?
He looked at me, he was just like...
HAHAHAHAHAHAHA!
HAHAHAHAHA!
I was like, you pulled...
TRIQuiter!
No, of course I didn't get drenched I was away from the fucking road I was like not, like he likes to be like super close to the road because he wants to be he was like I want To cross, I want to cross, I want to cross the road, I want to cross And I'm like I saw the giant puddle so I was like no,
do not get close to the road because the car is gonna fucking go
And then after he got splashed, he just looks at me and is like, you did this.
You did this to me.
I'm like, no, I did not.
You did this to your fucking self, you fucking idiot.
I pulled, I pulled on the fucking, I pulled on the leash.
I gave him a warning.
I pulled on the leash, but he wouldn't listen.
Anyway guys, it's silent.
Silent hill time.
Mother, why didn't you warn me?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I can't fucking speak, dog.
All right.
It's time.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I need to like hype myself up because I'm already tired.
It's time!
My brain needs to wake up.
Why did you not protect me?
All right, here we go.
Where am I?
Oh my god, why do I keep, oh, I remember why I was stopped here.
No, I remember now.
I remember why I stopped here.
This is where I saw the spider legs and I was like, I'm done.
I saw the spider legs and I was like, fuck this shit.
Fuck the spider legs.
Don't fuck, I know, don't fuck the spider legs, guys.
I know.
I know the spider legs, though.
They are very leggy, but don't fuck them.
All right, we went that way already, so we gotta go straight.
Nice,
okay, there's meds.
Oh my god, guys, do you think 20 is enough, guys?
Do you think?
Oh my god, I think this game is trying to tell me I do not need to take my meds.
I don't need to.
I just don't want to hear the voices.
If I take them, the voices will be gone.
Where have I not gone to?
Oh, it was here.
Wait, how do I get over here?
Do I just hit it?
Wait, what?
How do I get across?
Oh, I guess like here?
No, this door is locked.
So confused.
Oh, I haven't gone here.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Why is it so quiet and dark?
It's like Silent Hill is like silent.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought that Silent in Silent Hill means actually silent?
It's crazy.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Oh, I missed.
Alright,
didn't miss that.
Let's get down.
Like, he just looked at me.
Like, what?
I was just like, oh, hey there.
Hey, I didn't say that.
Wait a minute.
I don't remember that.
He was also still waking up.
Bro, I understand, man.
Bro, I understand, bro.
Okay.
Go this way.
Alright,
let's go.
Oh my god, did I really say that?
I fucking hate Pastor Oki.
I hate her.
I hate her so much.
Why would she do this to me?
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
I've been playing this game for 20 years.
My dragons have gotten married and have kids and I'm still...
But I'm still here trying to play this stupid game!
Get down!
They have kids now!
It's been 20 Halloweens!
Okay, we go this way.
Oh no, I hear them.
Oh, I hear them.
I hate this.
Oh my god, I hear the spiders.
I hear the spiders.
I'm never gonna leave this godforsaken lands.
Is this bait?
Oh my god, why is there ammo in the middle of the... in the middle?
It feels like bait.
Smash.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, that can't be that bad, right?
Anton, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
On October 11th...
Wait, why won't it let me go up?
Okay.
You declared Double or Nothing Top 500 in Overwatch 2 Season 13, which ends December 10, 2024, or suffer a penalty chosen by...
Oh no.
Wait, what date is it right now?
Wait.
Oh fuck, okay.
Oh no, those are pyramid head slashes.
Wait, I just noticed that.
Wait, that's only from Pyramid.
Oh no, wait, what date?
Oh, guys.
Guys, I'm only... I'm only Masters 2, guys.
Guys, I got to Masters 2 and then I stopped for two weeks because I got busy.
What the fuck?
Of course!
Of course it's the spider.
I was like, I was trying to read the map.
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
Yes.
I guess I go this way?
Yeah, ammo.
I knew it.
I knew this was going to happen.
I was like, they're going to pop by.
I fucking knew it.
Like, all those ammo bait...
Led to this moment.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm looking up.
Gamers, gamers, don't look up!
I knew it!
Fuck, oh shit, he still got me!
He
fucking kicked me in the shins!
The fucker kicked me in the goddamn shins!
Oh, alright.
You know, I think I'm making pretty good progress though.
Yeah, yep.
Honestly, I'm zooming.
Katis, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
I already got my first scientific publication posted.
Before Doki finishes Silent Hill, guys, at least GTA...
What?
Get back here!
Get your ass back here!
Go get your ass back here!
Bro, get over here!
Oh, okay.
Okay, now you wanna fight.
Nice.
Making my way downtown, walking fast.
What the fuck?
Oh, now you wanna walk back, okay.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
Ow!
Wait, did I dodge it?
I can't tell!
There's so many things happening on my screen!
Fine.
Okay.
Oh, there's another hole in the wall.
You know what that means, it's our favorite time of the year!
Gotta stick my hand through it.
Oh, there's a key.
Wait, when was the thing locked?
Not a good!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, where's this?
I don't remember this part.
Oh well.
It's a shortcut for something.
These photos you've been collecting... actually, do you spell out?
You've been here for two... I knew it, I fucking knew it.
I knew I've been here forever.
Alright.
A million VTubers have already finished this game and I'm still here.
They've finished it.
Wait, where do I go?
What was locked?
Where the fuck do I... which way?
Okay, one, two, or three.
I'm so confused.
I can't read maps, guys.
I don't remember where goes where.
Just one?
Where did I come from?
Did I come from a bird?
Okay, wait.
No, that makes sense.
No, I did.
So I'm a doki bird.
Here?
Oh, this!
Alright.
Easy.
Alright, up we go.
Jk, I can't... Oh!
Oh, come on!
Get over here!
Get down!
Stupid...
Stupid spider.
That's how you waste my fucking bullets!
Oh, I do not have a lot left.
I have like 13.
Who keeps repopulating the spider population?
I fucking knew it.
I looked up.
I knew it.
I was like, there's no way they would just let me... that would be too easy.
That would be too fucking easy.
Who keeps fucking the legs?!
They're just legs!
That's the best part.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
We have 10 bullets left.
Oh, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Please, please guys.
Stop banging the legs.
We gotta get... they're an invasive species.
They're gonna turn like into the iguanas in Florida!
Where am I?
Oh, there's ammo.
Are you serious?
They're all just rifle ammos.
I need pistols!
Guys, they're invasive species!
Stop creating more!
Okay, now we're at four.
The fuck is four?
Okay, we got the shortcut here.
Alright, I go forward.
Okay, under.
That's like... what?
Oh my god, it's not a safe spot.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, okay.
Can't go back now.
Hello?
No items?
What's that supposed to mean?
What?
I don't...
Oh, this way.
There's another hole.
I was getting a little angry.
This...
I'm gonna get like a wire cutter, I think.
Oh, there's way too many holes.
Which hole is the right hole?
Oh.
Oh shit, no, not again.
No, not again.
Okay.
James?
That's me.
Oh my
god, that is me!
That's me!
Hello?
Wait, is he gonna come in?
Oh my god, oh my god!
They can't come in!
I was like, I'm in a red room.
That's safe.
Does he climb ladders?
Okay, hello.
You can't get me!
Look at that, you might be able to open doors.
But you can't go through here.
You know what?
I'm gonna shoot you in the leg.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
What you gonna do?
Nothing!
That's right!
You might have a poseable thus!
But what can you do about steel bars?
Okay, let's go up.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, that was a little freaky.
I was like, I'm in a red room.
That means safe, right?
That's what the game has taught me this entire time, you know?
When you're in a red room and...
Woah!
You know, when they've taught me this entire time.
You would think that it means safe.
There we go.
I killed 75 enemies.
Oh, that's what I thought.
Alright.
All the safe points were red!
So I thought red equals safe!
It was this game's yellow!
Okay.
Now I know not all reds are safe.
Where the fuck am I?
Why would red be the new yellow?
Okay, I got syringes.
Nice.
Oh nice, I got the pliers.
I assume that's the shortcut, right?
Okay.
Alright.
I wanna go to- I haven't went to the other end, though.
Might be something at the other end.
Oh, oh nice!
Nice!
Oh thank god, handgun.
Oh my god, five bullets!
Oh my god, it's Christmas!
James!
Merry Christmas, James Thatcher!
You've been a good boy today!
Other than being a fucking sexual pervert, you've been a very good boy, so here's five bullets!
Yippee!
Alright.
Where's the wire?
Okay.
I don't
remember where anything is in this fucking world.
This world is so- Oh my god, where do I go in this fucking world?
I'm gonna go save.
See?
Red!
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, I- get there.
Cause I need to get to this side.
But how?
Oh my god, oh my fucking god.
Okay.
I assume... two?
I need to do like- I need to do like a little loop-de-loop here.
Okay.
Two.
Oh, I'm so fucking lost.
Okay, we gotta go to two, and then...
And then we go downstairs, and we have to hit the one, and then go to four!
Or is that five?
No, that's four.
Oh wait, the tunnel did collapse.
Wait, you're right.
Wait.
Wait, you're right, the tunnel collapsed.
No, you're right.
I have to go all the way around.
I forgot about that.
Oh no.
Does that mean I have to go all the way back?
Wait, really?
Wait.
No, there's no way.
There's no way it would do that to me.
No.
No, there's no way.
No, I can go through here.
Yeah, guys, there's no way.
Okay.
This is it.
No, no, I knew it.
I knew it, I remember I made a hole.
Okay.
And then the wires.
How the fuck am I- What?
How do I get there?
Oh, this is where it collapsed.
No.
I have to go back.
I actually have to go back.
No.
I made fun of him too.
Oh no.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I didn't mean to shoot you in the foot.
I swear it was an accident.
I swear, Mr. Pyramid Head.
It was an accident.
I swear to God.
My hand slipped.
I- My hand slipped.
I'm sorry, sir.
Okay, I have to do this way and then like- Wait, what?
Wait, what?
He's back?
Who fucking fucked another spider?
How do you- There's still more of you!
Okay, we gotta go this way back because I have to- Where's the hole?
There it is.
Because I had to go through this hole.
No, we have an invasive species problem!
You guys gotta stop!
Okay, now I'm here.
Okay.
I can do this.
Okay, I can do this.
What's the point of- What the fuck was the point of like- Having a shortcut here?
That shortcut is actually so bait.
That was such a bait shortcut.
Oh my God.
He's gone.
I don't like that he's gone.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh no.
I'm sorry for shooting your foot.
I'm so sorry.
Where did he go?
Because I- I don't know where he went.
I don't know where he went.
No way he went to lunch, right?
There's no way.
Where did he go?
He was there the whole time and now he's not?!
Okay.
Okay, I need to go in a straight and then cut wires.
Alright.
Stardew.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm not looking back.
If I don't look back, they don't exist.
Okay, here we go.
Made it.
Why is it red?
Okay, down we go.
Night, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Silent Hill?
That hill is really loud.
It's silent when I wish it wasn't silent though.
Please stop giving me meds.
Please.
I swear.
Please, I can't.
I want to hear the voices.
Hold time.
Yay!
Where am I?
Now where am I?
Oh.
What hill am I in now?
Oh, I'm back.
Yay!
Okay.
Back now.
Can I go through the arm now?
No.
Okay.
Do I still have to adjust this?
Wait.
Is this what I put in last time?
Guys, I have a little problem.
I...
Is this the section I was on?
Is this the section I was on or is this a new section?
Okay.
Where's your maps?
Dude, I don't fucking...
You think I know?
You think I know what it says?
Guys, I don't know which one I've done though.
Have I done this one yet?
Is this the one I just did?
I can't remember.
Did I do this one yet?
I don't remember!
I don't!
It might be.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Have I done this one before?
No, I haven't gone the right side yet.
Yeah, this is new.
Wait, that was easy.
Oh.
I
don't want it to be easy anymore.
No.
Guys, I don't want it to be easy no more.
Guys.
Why?
No!
I don't want it to be easy no more!
Yeah.
Wait, that door was open.
Oh my god.
I don't want it to be easy.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for calling it easy.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not a queen to ever cry.
I didn't know!
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go to the next level.
And the next one.
Oh, I'm going to have to fight again.
I'm going to get this guy out of the way first.
My buddy!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to fucking- Not you!
No!
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
It's not okay, but like it's okay.
There's still one more guy here.
I don't like this.
There you are.
Get over here.
Dodge!
Oh shit.
Oh.
I mean, that's cool.
You just- I mean, that's alright.
You just got a heart attack?
Fucking great.
I need that.
I'm glad he just- He just collapsed and just got a heart attack.
That was very helpful.
Like Kira just like came in and helped me.
This has to be timed or something.
I think.
I think this is timed.
He's like, what?
What?
Oh my god, I have like- I have like- Hang on.
I need more pistol, please.
Oh no.
So I'm gonna survive.
I don't know how many of these monsters are there.
No,
no, no!
Yoink.
Is this gonna work?
Oh shit!
Wait!
Wait, the spawners are here too!
That's illegal!
Little bitch is getting tired, right?
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so-
You guys will get tired eventually.
Yippee!
Please, come on!
Come on!
Is it over?
Fucking get a heart attack!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god!
Why is this so long?!
Is it over?
No, it's not.
No, it's definitely not over.
Oh my god, I'm sorry for saying that.
Is it over now?
Oh, it's over.
Okay, nice.
It was just that easy.
It's just that easy!
Nice.
Oh my god, this one had to be the easiest one.
Not gonna lie.
That's how- That's how you cheese a video game.
That honestly was the easiest one out of all of them.
Let's see.
Oh my god, nice meds.
Please, I didn't even shoot anything.
I need- I need- I don't need rifle!
No, I realized it was time when that one leg just fucking had a heart attack.
I was like, oh yeah, that's not normal.
That's not- That's not normal for that leg to have a heart attack.
Oh.
Guess I'll go into the- Oh.
Guess I can't go in there.
Oh.
Hello.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please!
Please keep going!
Oh my god, I'm in the room!
Why would I ever wanna leave?
Why would I- Why would I ever wanna leave?
Oh no, I left.
No.
No, but it was made for- No, but it felt so good!
It felt so- Oh my god, the paradise of legs!
Like, I should've stayed there for the longer if I knew it was just a- It was just like five seconds!
If I knew it was five- I didn't know they were taking away from me after!
Hello?
Maria?
Yeah, but they're existing legs!
We're not making new legs cause they're already there!
Wait, is she dead again?
Maria?
Oh shit, what?!
What happened to her?
Did someone throw acid on her face?
Maria?
Who did this to you?
Is that makeup?
Yeah, makeup is so powerful these days.
That's not wife, that's new wife.
Well, that's new dead wife, but like, he already knows what- I mean, that's not new for him.
Maria is dead now.
Now I- Maria who?
Now that the distraction is gone, I can focus on what really matters.
Oh, now you remember your actual dead wife.
That's so fucked.
Now he remembers her.
All he needed was for Maria to be dead.
Remember, Mary.
What's this?
Oh, that's his sword!
Oh, he does not like puzzles.
Oh my god, guys, look.
You guys know I lift?
That's right.
Wait, can I- Oh, I can still save, thank god.
I was gonna be like- Am I not allowed to save if I leave his sword there?
Hey, ladies.
That's right.
I lift.
Watch this.
Oh my god, I'm so strong.
Is this sexy, ladies?
Me barely able to pick up this giant sword?
That's so- Oh my god.
Back in paradise I go.
Look at that, ladies.
I can almost pick this up.
No, they're dying!
No!
But for life!
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
They were alive when he does it, but when I pick up the sword, they fucking just die.
They're like, oh, that is definitely not sexy.
I might as well just stop living.
Alright, down I go.
Hello.
Oh, hey, I get to touch grass.
Nice.
Don't have to go outside, the grass is inside.
Cringe to death.
They're just like, yeah, no, you are definitely not that strong.
Walter Sullivan?
Who's Walter again?
Miriam?
This fella drank one last bottle of alcohol before escaping and laid there.
Oh, hey, ammo.
Am I supposed to go in the hole?
Oh my god, am I supposed to go into the hole?
What's this, Angela?
Eddie?
Oh, and this is my hole!
James!
Why don't I go to his hole?
Oh, I can't go to his hole.
Alright.
Time to go to another hole.
I love holes.
Into another hole.
This hole was definitely made for me, though, this time.
Sorry, I tabbed out.
I had to check my sound real fast.
That's why you're like, wait?
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for your medal.
I always ask you, did you jump into your own grave like James did?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where am I at?
I don't like this.
Oh, there's the blood.
I was gonna say, I don't- this narrow hallway with no exit?
Oh, Eddie?
Wait, that's me.
Hi, James.
Hey, Eddie.
You okay there, buddy?
What's it look like I'm doing?
You fat, disgusting piece of shit, you make me sick.
You're gonna cry, fat ass?
You're gonna run to your mama?
Waste of skin, why don't you just kill yourself?
Whoa, in Minecraft?
Eddie, you're supposed to say in Minecraft, Eddie.
Eddie, you're supposed to say in Minecraft.
Oh!
Hey, Eddie, instead of like shooting in the corpse, can I have some of that ammo?
That pistol ammo that you seem to have a lot of?
Eddie, we just met.
Like five hours ago?
In game time?
For me, it was for like 20 years, but like...
Oh, shit!
Here, I have 20 fucking pill bottles that they keep stuffing me.
Huh?
That's me.
Wait, that looks just like me.
Wait a minute, Eddie.
Wait, that looks like me too!
Eddie, why are your bullies look like me?
Eddie!
Why do they all look like me?
Why?
Eddie, you got some explaining to do.
Why do they all look like me, Eddie?
Why?
What?
Oh, you killed a dog?
I'm bringing the big guns.
Oh, that's where I draw the line.
What the fuck?
Yeah, because you killed the dog!
Where is he?
What the fu
- I'm just gonna run to you.
That's so stupid.
Oh, shit, he's not dead?
Okay.
Takes the shotgun and just starts blasting.
Where is he?
This is personal now.
You got the dog involved.
This is personal.
I can see where you are, Eddie.
Wait, I lost him.
Oh, never mind, I lost him.
He
went right instead of left!
I don't care!
Thanks, Eddie.
What the fuck?
He just- He just gets his pistol and shoots it.
Here we go again.
Bro, how many shotgun bullets do you need?
I don't know where he is.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, what?
I fucking clearly was supposed to shoot first!
Oh, shit, no, I have to reload!
I have to reload, I'm sorry!
Okay, I'm going to reload everything first.
Alright.
What?!
Me first.
No, no, no, no!
No!
I moved at the last second!
That's so bullshit!
I would have gotten the kill!
Oh my god, I actually would have gotten the kill!
I moved at the last second!
Bro, fuck you, Eddie, I'm fucking coming after you!
It's the pigs!
It's RNG!
I got- I got RNG'd, guys!
That was pure RNG!
Look, I saw red when he got the dog involved, guys.
I saw red.
You don't understand.
I was not thinking.
He got the dog involved, so I stopped thinking.
All I wanted to do was shoot him.
What the fuck?
I have a gun.
Where did he go?
Where is he?
Ow!
Nice,
okay!
Alright, Eddie, I'm locking in now.
It might start moving, but I'm locking in.
Missy.
Over there.
It's
me!
That should not have hit me, guys.
That should not have hit me.
Over there.
Stop running, please, for the love of god.
There we go, that's right!
I'm locked in!
Oh, he's so fucking fast!
I had to... Guys, you don't understand.
The first time I died, I was mad.
He got the dog involved, chat.
You don't understand.
I was not thinking.
I was like, how dare... I don't care about the guy you killed.
That looks just like me, which is a little concerning.
But, you got the dog involved.
How come he can take like 20 shots?
Oh, I killed a man, too.
Yep, James, you did that.
A human being.
But he deserved it.
He deserved it.
He killed a dog, James.
You gotta remember that.
It was self-defense.
Exactly.
All dogs are safe now.
Oh, I'm on the outside!
Oh, man.
There we go.
Back to my pistol.
Oh, into the boat I go.
What's the boat for?
Wait, you're right.
He said that while I was wearing my dog cosplay.
That's so fucked.
He knew what he was getting into.
He knew exactly.
He should not have said that to me when I was in my dog cosplay.
Okay.
Row, row, row.
Row, row.
Where would I go?
Maybe if I keep rowing forward, it will lead me to the place.
See?
Dad agrees with me.
He's like, that's right!
Preach it!
Preach it, doggy!
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can't believe Eddie didn't watch John Wick.
Should have known to never get exactly.
You should have known.
He knew exactly what he was getting into.
Am I going the right way?
Oh.
I mean, I'm following this light over there.
Right?
Oh.
Oh yeah, the light's here.
Yeah.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know for a fact you ain't getting the dog ending.
But it's heavily speculated in the OG that dog in the ending was the same one Eddie- Wait, he killed a sheep?!
I'm literally wearing his head!
Oh my god, I'm like his biggest fan.
That's right, you should have never confessed to me.
That was his biggest mistake, confessing the kill.
I'm literally his biggest fan.
I'm wearing his fucking head right now.
I bought that at DogCon 2024.
How fucking dare he.
I avenged my Oshie.
That's literally my Oshie right there.
Guys, it's okay, I already knew about the dog ending.
But I didn't know that- I didn't know that was the dog that he might have killed.
Well, I'm here now.
Oh my god, it's like so foggy.
You gotta rename this town Solid Foggy Hill.
I still have to go up.
Oh hey, I remember this place.
Which way do I go?
I don't have my map anymore.
Go this way?
Oh, is this Mary's favorite place?
Has the cold draw near as they abandon their own nest to return in time.
Is this her special place?
Is there any ammo?
Maybe Mary left some ammo.
In her special area.
In her special place.
Mary,
can you do me a solid and leave some ammo for me?
I don't think there's anything here.
I don't think so.
Alright.
Oh, it's here.
Special places spark fires that warm our hearts forever.
Oh, it's back here!
Our room!
Okay.
Okay, this is- We're not close to our room.
Good to know.
Oh, nice save.
Alright, save.
Oh my god, I knew it.
She was still alive!
She wants to hook up!
I fucking knew it!
Key and ornament key.
312.
Is that our special place?
There's three floors?
312.
Oh.
Is this a booty call?
Did Mary send me a ghost booty call?
Oh Mary, you're so silly.
Oh my god, she sent me a ghost booty call.
She's so silly.
Nice, more meds.
102.
Oh, there's gonna be a lot of monsters in this hotel.
I can feel it already.
I can feel it.
What's this?
Paranormal flirtation.
What would I even like- What would I even be like, if I have a ghost booty call?
It's like, they're not physical, so it's like, how does that even work?
Knock knock.
Anything in the bathroom?
But don't they just pass through you?
Mr. or Mrs. Ghost.
Wouldn't it be so sexy if you could look inside me right now?
Oh my god.
Come and ectoplasm me.
It's like, some ghosts leave ectoplasm, right?
It's like, oh my god.
Hey there, come and ectoplasm me right now.
What?
Oh my god.
Bro?
Bro,
she left me to die.
How am I okay with her?
Oh my god.
I'm like, calm.
She literally left me to die.
Yes, death is not real.
Tell her.
Tell her death isn't real.
She's eight.
She doesn't know.
Who's Rachel?
Yeah.
Oh, we share nurses.
Yeah, I know she doesn't see silent.
She sees normal, but...
Like, she still locked me inside.
Like...
Like,
how did she think I was gonna get out?
Laura.
Laura, don't tell Mary about the other woman, okay?
Don't tell her about Mary.
Don't tell her about Maria.
Also the nurses, too.
Yeah, but then she heard me talk about Maria.
Maria, that's the thing.
Yeah, I mean...
Wait, what?
Oh my god, I knew it.
I fucking...
I knew she faked her death.
She faked her death and then moved to a hospital with Laura.
So then, like, and then pretended that.
I fucking knew it.
I knew my doctors were wrong.
She faked my death to leave me.
No, no, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Figured you didn't deserve to have it.
It was for the life insurance, guys.
Guys, it must be for the life insurance.
Well, where is it then?
Okay, I knew she wasn't dead.
I fucking knew it.
I knew the doctors were wrong.
We didn't see the bo- I mean, we did see the body during the open casket.
But, like, how did we know it was her body?
We didn't do a blood test of the corpse.
They couldn't- makeup is very powerful these days.
They could've put makeup on the body that's clearly not Mary and then pass it off as Mary.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I was right.
I knew it.
I knew she has always been alive.
They cloned her.
That could be it.
Oh, no.
Now it's definitely- Oh, come on.
Really?
I fucking knew it.
She's never dead.
I knew she was never dead in the first place.
They were all clones.
It was makeup.
We never did a DNA test on the body.
Aftermath.
Anything here?
No.
Oh, nice.
More rifle.
I mean, I have a clone too.
It's Pyramid Head.
He looks just like me.
Guys, in every way.
Where is it?
There he is.
Oh, shit.
I'm not expecting him to fight back.
I'm gonna go this way.
See if there's ammo.
Nice.
Hey, I don't make the rules.
Of course my clone would be Pyramid Head.
He's literally in my head.
What?
Where did she come from?
Okay, I don't know where the fuck she came from there.
Okay.
Where the fuck did she pop up?
Like, is there any way here?
Was it really from here and I didn't see?
I have 102.
I explored.
More syringes.
Nice.
Can I have some pistol ammo, please?
Oh, I don't need rifle rounds, but okay.
That's alright.
Oh, rifle and shotgun?
Oh my god.
Have I reloaded everything yet?
Okay, no.
Let me make sure I have everything reloaded.
No, no, I can't.
I can't take my meds.
I can't take my meds because Mary will disappear.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry for laughing.
I just wanted to shoot you in the knees.
I can't go to staff only.
I can go outside though.
I can touch grass.
Oh, thank god.
More handgun ammo.
I need this so badly.
Wait,
can I cross this?
Oh, nice.
What do I do?
Here?
Anybody hiding?
Any little freaks here?
In the hotel?
Calling all freaks?
There's no loot?
Oh my god, what?
There has to be nothing?
That's actually so- This room had nothing.
That's so bullshit.
Oh, I'm back here.
Oh.
I didn't realize this was a way.
What the fuck was the point of being here?
There's actually nothing here.
You get nothing, dookie.
Isn't that great?
Oh.
That's not cool.
Just got back up.
What?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Who are you?
Where did you come from?
Alright.
Where did this girl come from?
Just got up in front of me.
Wait, does that mean the others get back up too?
No.
Are we back in the area where they all just get up?
No, that's not fair.
What do you mean they can just get back up?
No.
That's the one thing I don't want.
Helix seems to have some kind of pest separate from the rest of the plants or it'll all die.
This is Sunrise Winky.
I'm sad now.
I'm sad because that means they can all come back to life.
I thought we were over that.
I thought that was over.
I thought we moved past it.
Okay.
It's obviously here.
So...
I gotta go back to the beginning.
Sunrise Wing.
Gotta go to Sunrise Wing.
And then I have to remember where the save point is.
I think it's here?
Yeah.
Goddammit.
Why does this hotel have all the keys just lying conveniently to here?
Wait, what?
I have a special tape?
Wait, where's the save?
Where would the save be?
Wait, this is the first floor.
This is not the first floor?
Oh no, what kind of tape is it?
Oh, god.
James, what kind of tape was it, James?
Employee section.
Oh, I can't even get there.
I can't even get to the employee section.
Why do I want to be in the basement?
The basement seems to be the freakiest area.
So I'm gonna head back upstairs.
Maybe I'll go upstairs.
Feels a little less freaky.
Yeah, we have to be upstairs anyway.
Oh.
Oh, I hear people.
Hello?
I
don't like this room.
I really don't like this room.
I really do not like this room at all.
202.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I knew you were...
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I fucking knew you were there.
Get down.
Why are you so stinky?
I knew you were hiding there.
You little bitch.
John, thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
7-4-1-4?
What does that mean?
I have an apple.
Whoa!
Oh, it's a safe!
It's a freaky safe!
I don't remember it.
You!
That's it.
I'm tired of this.
It's a freaky safe.
Oh my god.
My hero.
Again?
Oh my god.
Don't worry, Mary.
I'll make sure no one watches that video.
As your dying wish.
I'll make sure nobody will know this video exists.
Nurse's office.
I'd like to go to the reading room because there's a question mark.
I'm gonna go to the reading room first.
It's like there's question marks at the reading room.
So like, I feel like it's like...
Maybe you should go there.
Oh, because it's a safe point.
Oh, that makes a lot of sense now.
Okay.
The one who's sword.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry, Mary.
I'll make sure it's safe.
What?
Oh, I have to place the books.
I don't know what any of these mean.
Pride before the fall.
How the fuck do I sort this out?
What?
How?
Oh, I... Okay.
I'll never learn, I guess.
Let's go.
Oh.
I don't... I don't understand.
What did that all mean?
What did the numbers mean?
217?
Oh, this is a spooky room.
What?
There's another puzzle within a puzzle?
Oh, who keeps taking these photos?
Shadow, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I need to find a lightbulb.
What's this puzzle within a puzzle?
Have I already found this one yet?
No, I must not have.
I brute-forced the other puzzle.
So, I feel... I don't know how I solved this one.
But, okay.
Shadow, in the corner you didn't decide to go, there was another apple on the bench there.
Wait, which corner?
There were a lot of corners, guys.
There was a lot.
You gotta be more specific there.
A painting?
There was a painting?
Oh!
I'm just that smart.
I, like, subconsciously...
I subconsciously took that in.
I guess, like, I have to get the red light and it'll, like, solve this one.
So, I need to find a lightbulb.
Oh, was it the outside?
Like, this outside?
Here?
Or the bottom floor outside?
Oh my god, it was the ragdoll.
This outside?
I assume it's the bottom floor, right?
Wait, I am playing on standard.
How do I tell?
How can I prove it to you?
Wait, where...
I've been on window this entire time?
No, I'm on fullscreen.
Okay.
There's an apple in that room outside in the garden area?
There's no apple, you fucking liars.
Where's the apple?
Yasmin, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just had a big fight with my husband, but watching you play this game is making me so happy.
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no, I hope you feel a lot better.
Thank you so much for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
In that room?
This room?
The room where it's making little sounds right now going...
Hey!
Is there an apple in this room?
Oh, the room of all... No, I already got the apple though.
Unless there's another apple I missed.
I got one of the apples.
I got this apple.
There's no way there's another apple.
Is there another apple I missed?
Oh, I only need one.
Good.
Staff only?
I'm staff, technically.
Okay.
Alright, down we go.
Hello?
If I say hello, you gotta say hello back.
It's the rules.
Hello?
Please say hello back.
Oh!
I'm sorry!
You're supposed to say hello back!
Guys, I meant verbally!
Say hello back!
Verbally!
Instructions uncleared.
I started slapping.
Alright, this way.
She don't have no... Bro, she's just legs.
What did she expect?
She doesn't have a mouth.
I don't know, I thought... I don't know, she could've just waved.
She didn't need to get physical.
Oh.
Oh, do you think he's okay?
Oh, there you go.
Oh
god, it still hit me.
It actually still hit me.
Oh my god, I knew there was gonna be a 2v1 and I still got hit!
Oh please, I think... I'm wasting so much meds in this area.
There's too many fucking flankers.
Hello?
Any hellos back?
No hellos?
Alright, I came from here.
Why does no one wanna say hello to me?
That guy just walked away, I don't like that.
Do you think he knows I'm in this room?
Okay, nice handgun ammo.
Please.
Oh my gosh, thank you, more meds.
Alright.
Oh no, oh!
Can't waste any more ammo on these guys.
Oh shit, oh fuck, okay.
Gotta get the cockroach too.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Get back here!
No, you're staining the floor!
The chat worked so hard on that!
Bro, you like stained the carpet!
What the fuck happened to the bed?
Why is this just a- oh, there's nothing in here.
I don't like this room.
There's just- it's just- there's nothing.
This room is way too freaky for me.
This literally has nothing in there.
You know something is wrong when this room is just an empty room.
Oh, is this where I put my apple?
Huh?
Oh!
Okay.
Another puzzle.
Oh no, that's not how it goes.
Okay, we're gonna put this down.
This one has to be here.
And then...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, shapes.
Fucking shapes.
I love shapes so much.
Yeah.
Wait, we're missing one.
Oh no, it's right here.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait.
Wait, why can't I pick up this?
No, we are missing one!
Oh, that's just like telling me like, there's one missing here.
We are!
Oh, it's right here.
Why is it just sitting in the bed like that?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Momo.
Yeah!
There you go.
That's me!
Oh my god, I made a portal!
Wait, did I make a portal?
I made a portal.
How do I get there?
Wait, does that mean like, this changed?
Wait, what the fuck?
Back up.
That's illegal.
Yay!
Okay, well that's no white figurine.
Oh, so that's why it was empty.
Oh my god, it makes so much more sense now.
I was like thinking like, why is it so empty?
Are you serious?
Where did that sound come from?
Someone is alive!
Who is it?
Is there a shortcut anywhere?
I heard someone being alive!
It's you.
It's you, it's always you.
It's always you!
Why are there so many again?!
This fucking sucks.
This actually sucks so much.
I hate them.
I hate them, I hate them so much.
It's like, every time I kill one, another one gives birth to a hundred spiders.
It never stops, we need to find the nest.
We need to stop it from the source.
These are the worst, these are the worst.
These are actually the worst monsters in this entire game.
Alright,
save time.
You don't understand, Doki.
The legs, I can't stop myself.
It's the legs, Doki.
You don't understand.
Every time I think of a leg, another one pops up.
It just keeps happening.
Every time.
M-S-S, okay.
It just keeps happening.
I think of a leg and I'm like, oh fuck!
Like that, what's his name?
Paul Rudd.
The Paul Rudd clip.
Everything he thinks of is like, fuck!
Another one just shows up.
And that's the shortcut.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, where am I now?
I'm in the employee area.
Okay, is there anything extra here?
Nice, more shotgun.
Oh!
Okay, do I have...
No, I don't have the employee elevator.
Do I have anything?
Like, where am I?
Okay, I'm here.
Can I go up?
Oh, I can technically.
Okay, I'll explore downstairs first.
More shotgun.
I used all of that on fucking Eddie's big stomach.
Bro, his stomach tanked like 20 shots.
That's not okay.
Like...
You gotta see a doctor if you can tank 20 fucking shotgun shots.
And you guys can be like, yeah, but it's like extra protection.
That's what the blubber is for.
It's like a seal blubber.
You know?
You have all that blubber to like, insulate heat and stuff, but like...
Eddie is like, literally a bullet vest.
But like, I don't think that's healthy.
A natural bullet vest.
Guys, I don't think that's healthy.
What?
Like, I think you might need to see a doctor.
If...
If your blubber... if your...
Your blubber can protect yourself from bullets.
Huh.
I don't have a point... I never played the original Silent Hill 2, so I don't have a point of reference of that.
But then it might look cool for you guys.
You guys might be like, oh my god, it's that thing.
I'm like, woah.
Oh, you keep... oh, come on.
Get up.
Get up!
There we go.
She got up.
Okay, am I on the third floor?
Yeah!
I am!
I'm on the third floor now.
We're getting closer to seeing her.
Conference room.
I don't like how empty this conference room is.
It's way too empty.
It's a little freaky.
Can I use this?
Oh, I have to pick it up.
It says it's taking this long to get into the conference room.
You might as well drop by room 107.
I'm leaving you a key.
One of the guests has made quite a mess.
Okay, we gotta go to 107 then.
Time to backtrack.
Oh, I love backtracking.
Yippee!
Let's go!
Backtracking.
I'm gonna cry.
Back to backtracking.
What?
Mary?
Oh, Mary, I know you called my name out, but I gotta explore this area first.
I gotta get some loot.
Whoa, shit!
What the fuck?
I shot you in the knee!
Okay, I definitely shot him in the knee there.
Wait, what was the bolt cutters for?
Oh!
Wait, no.
What was the...
What was the bolt cutters for?
Hey, good thing I'm a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, can you check on me?
Wait, what's...
Is she playing Devil May Cry?
Is she being a little scaredy cat?
Alright, nice.
I wanna fucking play Silent Hill 2.
She's scared of Devil May Cry?
How do I get to over there?
Oh, I'm outside.
Yay!
Wait, how do I...
Why am I here?
217... Oh, I haven't been here before!
Oh my god, it's a bird room!
Wait, how do I get that?
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, do I need another book?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
Every time I go to a new room, I'm just like, where am I?
I just... I get so confused.
Like, so lost.
New room, disoriented.
Okay.
Okay, smash!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he welcomed me to his home!
And then I killed him.
We're here to find the spider nest.
Now where am I?
Okay, so we got through the employee area.
And then we did the vanity mirror.
I don't know why it's not crossed out, because we did that.
Oh no, the vanity mirror is the red lightbulb.
Did we finish the third floor?
Can't remember.
We looked at 213 already?
213 is locked.
Did
we finish this room?
Yeah, we did.
What happened to my items?
I mean...
Oh my god, what was the bolt cutter for?
Can I cut it in the conference room?
Is it this?
No.
Oh my god, okay, I need to use the bathroom.
Oh my god, my stomach.
I always get like, whenever I play Silent Hill, I get like so nervous and then my stomach goes like...
Alright, there's no way I'll die if I just look at this, right?
Nobody's just gonna come up and fucking shank me, right?
I'll be right back.
Oh my god, I'm safe!
No one came up to fucking shank me!
Or kick me with their sexy legs!
Oh my god, thank god.
No, the only thing I would hate so much is if a leg would just kick me just now.
That would be so bad if that would have happened.
Alright, this way.
I guess I have to go to the first floor?
I'm gonna go to the first floor, open 107.
Okay, save.
That would be so unfortunate if that happens.
Okay, 107.
107 is right here.
Alright, let's see who came back alive.
Any alivers?
Okay, knew it.
I fucking knew it!
Joke is they all came back alive.
Oh shit, he fucking headbutt me.
Alright, let's see.
107.
It's right here.
Where the fuck is the ornament key?
Hello?
I didn't see this.
Note to staff, and while you're at it, be sure to sweep up the leaves in the garden.
Then, you can get back to the fireplace.
Oh, am I supposed to burn it?
Wait, what?
Oh my god, these guys got fucking rowdy here.
Bet she's on the floor too?
What were they up to?
That's a person.
Butt shot.
Okay, she like moved her head.
She literally like rotated her head.
Hello?
Smack you in the butt.
That's right, butt shot.
Okay, I have to make sure there's no other secret hiding guy here.
Wait, there's another guy.
I hear him.
Hello?
She said hi back.
See, this is how you say hi.
Oh my god, she like actually camouflaged so well.
It's not fair.
Oh, when I swap my Minecraft skin, I'm a tryhard.
But when he does it, he's just sexy.
It's not fair.
What's this?
Fireplace key.
Oh, okay, now we can get the thing.
Doki, please.
Doki, you're just projecting now.
No, I'm not!
What the fuck?
What is he?
He's like playing on the leaves.
Is this fun time?
Oh, it's like extra toxic because it's black too.
It's like black toxins.
I can't go through here.
Well, I got the fireplace key.
He's like, bro, bro, it's my fucking...
Bro, normally I never get free out time.
Bro, why you gotta do that?
Yeah, I'll go outside.
It's just faster.
Is there a way to go... Is there a shortcut that's faster this way?
No, there isn't.
Just fuck me, I guess.
Hey, what's that over there that's circled?
Oh!
That's what it was for!
I just never looked at it.
Alright, I'll go save and then we'll head outside.
That's the bathroom, sorry.
Sorry, I had to use the bathroom.
James had to use the bathroom too.
Alright, save time.
Alright,
let's go outside.
To the garden we go!
Nothing bad happens in the garden.
It's such a nice place.
Look how pretty everything is.
There's the lightbulb!
Nice.
Okay, we found the lightbulb.
Large one on the west.
Okay.
We gotta go back to the vanity, mirror, and then the fireplace, and then...
Oh my god, there's so many backtracks.
How do we get there?
It's up here.
And then we go up.
James, why couldn't you just leave everything in one area?
I don't understand.
Why didn't it be so fun and everything was very conveniently placed in locations where...
You know, I can just go there and it'll be fine?
Or is that silly?
Mirror first.
Lightbulb.
Wait, what?
Is it because it's not red?
How do I make this lightbulb red?
Wait.
How do I make it red?
It's not red though.
What if I bleed on it?
What if I chew my foot and then bleed on the lightbulb?
Does that work?
Okay, fireplace is... okay, we gotta go this way.
It's okay, it's just a little blood.
How else would I solve the puzzle if I don't bleed on it?
It's like the most easiest solution, James.
We don't need to find anything else.
Fireplace key.
I still don't know what to do with these.
What happened?
Pyramid head?
Is that you?
Oh, is that boss?
Wait, wait, guys, guys, is this a boss?
Guys, is he a boss?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh shit, it's not fine.
Okay, now I know.
Oh god, oh god.
Whoa!
Oh,
he fucking flings himself?
Wait, he wasn't a boss.
He was so easy to kill.
Is he dead?
Wait, that's it?
That's it?
What?
What the fuck, you're so fucking weak.
You're such a loser.
Bro, all the other bosses were actually hard for you to...
And he was harder than you.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
And he was harder.
And he's like a mad.
You're like supposed to be like my dirty thoughts.
Oh, it's just a mini boss?
Okay, okay.
Why does he look like that?
Because I'm lonely.
What?
You'll understand if you're also lonely.
You just don't understand.
Alright, here we go.
Yay, we're on the other side now.
Doki is already on the ground.
Wasn't the other guy chilling on the ground enough?
Thank you for the super chat, Momohaku.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't need help.
I just need Mary, who's very much alive.
Can I dip my lightbulb onto this blood?
Oh yeah, I can!
Okay, and then...
James, you need to clean those afterwards.
Lostcore, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, now it's red.
Wait, what?
It cannot be opened?
Wait.
Where is it?
Where's my fucking key items?
Oh my god, I can't open.
I'll use my key.
I should be, like, allowed to use my key to open this.
Where do I go?
Yeah, I should be allowed to use my key to open this.
Where the fuck do I go now?
Like, I have a music box, but, like...
Oh, the key item I shot down.
You're right, I forgot about that.
Where did I shoot it down, though?
That's the thing.
Guys, where did I shoot that thing down?
I forgot about that item.
That, like, never existed to me.
It's not marked in my map.
I definitely know I did not shoot a can opener, though.
I should just put the paint on the ground and then just shoot it.
I just need a hole to dip a light bulb in.
That's literally it.
That's the bathroom.
Fuck, it's the piano room.
Okay, it's there, like, shorty restaurant.
It's a restaurant.
There we go.
That's where I shot it.
Oh, there it is!
There's the can opener.
Oh, thank god.
And then, the light bulb.
There we go, it's finally red.
Thank fucking god.
Alright, we gotta...
We gotta save, then put the light on the thing, and then do the vanity mirror, and then find my tape.
I still remember about the tape.
Who opens a can- I'm- He lost- He is trying to find his wife now, and you're gonna- He has been- James has been through a lot.
And you're gonna judge him for his can opening?
I fucking knew you were alive.
I knew it.
Get down from here, you fucking whore.
Or I'll just do the mirror.
Alright.
Deed done.
Is that it?
Deed...
What happens if I like, skip all that?
Like...
If I just put deed done, without going through like, 30 minutes of all that puzzle?
Employee elevator.
Okay.
I'm gonna save it.
Elevator's right here.
Alright, I'm not dealing with the spiders.
I'm not- I have more important things to worry about right now.
I can't...
I can't deal with them again.
Not again.
Oh hey, I saved.
Oh my god, am I close to the end?
I feel like I've been playing for 20 years.
I've been stuck in Silent Hill for so long.
I don't even know if I'm making good progress.
Wait, why do we store items?
Wait, what?
What?
Why would I want to store items?
Wait, I don't understand.
I- I don't understand.
I- I don't like- Wait, what?
I just put my books down?
Okay.
James.
We should've went on- we should've lifted- we should've went on a diet, James.
We should've- and not just pick up one pistol.
Just one pistol.
Just let me hold my pistol, please.
Like, that's- Like, there's no way one pistol.
I can't even hold the pistol.
James, we're too thick.
We're too thick, James.
We're too thick.
James.
Oh no, I see him.
Like, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, this is it.
Wait.
4-1.
What was it?
No, I don't remember.
It was 20 years ago.
I'm fucking- where's my notes?
Where's my notes?
4-1 something.
It was 4-1 something.
No.
No, it overwrote.
No!
I don't see it no more!
It got overwritten.
4-1-1-4.
4-1-4.
4- No, please.
Please, I need my tapes.
4- 4-1-1-4.
4-4-4-1-4-1-7.
I knew it started with a 4!
4-4-3-4-2- That's all I remember!
No.
4-1- 7-4-4-7-4-1-4.
I
did it.
I don't know where to go now.
I didn't think I'd make it this far.
Like, what do I do here?
What do I do here?
Just won't wash off water sheets.
Oh, the video.
You wanna watch a video with me?
It's a freaky video.
How do I watch the freaky video?
Oh, there's a map.
Okay.
TV room.
How do I get out?
The fuck do I leave?
How do I leave this area?
Yeah.
Hey there.
Goodbye.
It's nice seeing you, bro.
Cool seeing you there.
Bye.
Wait, can I come back there with my gun?
Can I go back there with my gun and kill him?
Bro, I can't even fight him!
I can't do anything!
How do I get out?
Wait.
I don't like this guy.
I don't like him.
Oh my god.
I hate this area.
I hate this area so fucking much!
Okay.
We gotta go to the maintenance room and grab the thing.
Hey.
Goodbye.
Bro, I'm running.
I'm running as fast as I can, man.
I'm running as fast as I can!
I'm sorry for calling you weak earlier.
I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry for calling your brother weak.
You're so much cooler than your brother.
If I knew you guys had siblings, I wouldn't have done it.
Okay.
Spin.
Spin!
I don't even have flashlights.
What?
Is it here?
Okay.
Take it back.
Spin to live.
Spin!
Just keep spinning!
Come on, James!
Just spin!
Hello.
Oh no.
Wait.
Is this when I got angry?
No, this is a different place.
Oh my god.
My heart is like thumping.
Oh hey, there's another one.
Oh, she's cute.
It's a little mermaid.
Can I grab my stuff back?
Hello?
Where is this area?
Oh, it's the basement.
It's the basement.
Guys, where did I leave my...
Where did I leave my stuff?
I don't remember.
I don't remember where I left my stuff.
Was it in the basement?
It's been so long.
Notice that.
Be sure to clean up the fireplace in the conference room.
Oh my god, where was it?
Wasn't there a shortcut?
Oh, second floor to the left.
Guys, they took away my map.
They took away the one thing that was keeping me alive.
My map.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, I got everything back.
Thank fucking god.
Did I really need a cutscene of me picking my stuff up?
That's it?
Why did I need a cutscene for that?
What?
Absolute cinema.
That was the best cutscene I've ever seen, chat.
I feel so fucking immersed now.
What do I do now?
That peek was so vital to the plot, Doki.
You don't understand.
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
I never found the item for the music box.
I
don't think I ever found the item for it.
Wait, I did?
Like, I never found, like, where to put it in.
It's at the end?
Oh, shit!
Is that what it was?
I thought that was decoration.
I didn't realize that was... Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize that was, like, part of the game.
I thought it was just to decorate it.
Alright.
Found it.
Okay, mermaid in there.
That's correct.
Is it moving this?
Okay, that's correct.
That's not correct, sorry.
That's correct.
There we go.
That should be it.
Okay, but this is correct now.
Is it not?
Oh, I'm so dumb.
But it's not moving it, though.
Cuz that's correct, cuz it hits everything here.
Guys, I just figured it out.
I was so confused about the center.
Oh my god, I didn't realize the center was its own thing.
How the fuck do we do this part?
I'm so stupid.
Cuz how do we connect that to there?
Okay, that's connected now.
That should all be connected here.
Is that it?
How the fuck do I connect these guys?
We did it.
What?
I'm confused.
Wait, what does it all do?
What?
If I press it, what happens?
What begins with 3?
1?
The phase 2?
What begins with 3?
1 would soon deploy.
7 kindly souls, open the door.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
7, 5, 1?
1.
Oh!
I did it!
Cuz at the end, it's like 7, 5, 1.
What the fuck?
Okay, I figured it out.
I'm so smart.
I thought it was like, that says 7.
The other one says 5.
And the last one said 1.
Is that it?
I was like, okay.
Third floor.
How do I get to the third floor?
Is it this way?
I think it's this way.
And then...
Wait, what?
Oh, I figured it out.
Wait, no, that goes downstairs.
This way.
Now I'm on the third floor.
And there's a padlock.
Mary, I'm coming over, Mary!
This is it, Mary!
I'm
coming over for the ghost booty call, Mary!
Wait, what's this?
Observation room?
Who's gonna be observing us?
Mary?
Who did you invite?
Mary!
Mary?
Mary, where are you?
Mary, it's been three years, Mary.
I have not done anything for three years.
She's not dead.
It was all fake.
She faked her own death, guys.
Boo.
What's the video?
Mary?
Yeah, I gotta prepare for tonight.
Why?
There's no view.
It's just fog.
Why don't we just move here?
We love Silent Hill so much.
Huh?
Like, Kierman had overrated my video with thirst traps?
Did I kill Mary?
I fucking smothered her?
I didn't want to take care of her anymore, so I killed her.
Look, we live in America, Laura.
You gotta understand.
Like, those bills were getting way too high.
Look, our insurance didn't cover it, Laura!
Our insurance couldn't cover it!
I'm sorry.
Mary, you know, isn't here.
Oh my god, what?
Wait, why did I kill her?
Well, thank you for the superchat, thank you.
Dog mask makes the scene peak.
Oh no, I'm in the other world.
Oh no.
Mary?
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired, Mary.
You were sick, but like, it wasn't terminal.
So I had to make it terminal.
I thought that was Kierman head.
I didn't realize that was me choking her or smothering her to death.
I was like, is that Kierman head making a thirst trap right now over my wife's video?
But no, it was me making a thirst trap.
Or not thirst trap, trying to kill her.
What room did she say she was in?
Wait, that was the other world?
This is the real hotel?
Go the other way?
Oh no, it's this way.
Wait, then what the fuck, then Laura was running around here!
Laura didn't find it weird that we were running around this burned down hotel?
Laura, you have some issues.
I know you're an orphan, but like, this is bad.
What the fuck?
I don't know where I'm going.
There's so many holes.
I've never been so lost.
Okay.
Now I'm here.
Is this way?
What's the point of the loop-de-loop there?
Where am I now?
Wait, there's a question mark behind me.
Then there's a hole here.
See, it's because I stopped taking my meds.
I mean, it's because I started taking my meds, so I started remembering things again.
When I didn't take my meds, I was in full denial and I was happy.
I was happy that I didn't kill my- thinking that I didn't kill my wife.
What am I supposed to do with this?
Still can't get it right.
Is there like a crevice here?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, let me check what's on the other side first.
What does that say?
There's no healing of the- thy bruise, thy wound is grievous.
Okay, we got more ammo.
Alright, time to push this thing over.
Weeee!
Okay, nice.
Oh.
Oh, I guess it's time to jump down again.
Back to the hole we go.
Back to another hole!
Yeah!
Of course I have to go down another hole.
The holes never stop.
We have to fight Pyramid Head soon.
This feels very Pyramid Head-ish.
Oh, it's not a problem if the game keeps enabling me.
This feels very Pyramid Head-coded.
Wash yourself, make yourself clean, remove the evil of your deeds from my sight.
Oh no.
Looks like Pyramid Head colors.
Feels very Pyramid Head-coded.
Oh my god, alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Got my shotgun out just in case.
Hello?
Mr. Head?
Mr. Head, is that you?
Oh my god, it's so quiet.
It's just so quiet.
Mr. Head!
We're not close enough to be Pyram- Mr. Pyram- Mr. Pyram- I can't call him by his first name.
Mr. Head is his father.
Please call me Pyramid.
We're not close enough.
We're not tight enough to be- for me to call him by his first name.
We ain't close like that, guys.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
It's just so, like, quiet.
It's like way too quiet.
I hate it.
Oh my god, is this it?
Is this where I fight Mr. Head?
Pyramid Conehead?
Hello?
No, not the water.
Oh...
Okay.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
The things I do for my dead wife who I killed.
Well, now that I know I killed her, I can just leave, right?
Like, I know she's definitely dead-dead.
So, like, I should just leave!
You know she's not alive!
Yeah, we might as well go now.
Oh, okay.
Down we go.
And you just drive off.
Is this where I fight him?
Is this where I fight my inner- my inner demons?
Oh, Angela?
Mama?
I was looking for you.
You're the only one left.
Maybe then I can finally rest.
Mama?
What's wrong?
It's mommy.
Wait.
You're not my mama.
It's- it's you.
I can be.
I can be your mama.
You want that.
What?
I killed him for you.
I deserve what happened.
Oh my god.
That is not true.
That's fucked.
Don't pity me.
I'm not worth it.
Or maybe you think you can save me?
Of course.
I'm the protagonist.
Everything is fixable, Angela.
Would you love me?
Whoa!
Care for me?
Heal all my pain?
I don't think I can fix her at this point.
Oh my god, no.
She's like, can you fix me?
No, no, no.
Don't say that.
No.
I'm gonna be so tempted to fix you.
Give me back the knife.
No, I won't.
Saving it for yourself.
No, my weakness.
I'm fixing her.
Have it your way.
It doesn't change anything.
Angela, we can get therapy together.
We've both murdered people.
Yours is self-defense and mine is technically self-defense from monetary debt.
It's hot as hell in here.
You see it too?
For me, it's always like this.
Oh, everything blurring.
Oh, so it's not real.
James, touch the fire.
It's not real.
I just leave her?
James, what the fuck?
Don't you wanna fix her, James?
I just leave her?
Okay, James is not a good guy.
I mean, he did kill his wife, but like...
Now I definitely know he's not a good guy.
He's like, I cannot fix that.
Oh!
Whoops.
I'm not supposed to kill them now?
Like, I got fucked up.
Like, oh my god.
No, now I'm fucking...
Oh my god, now I feel bad.
Why are you scared of me?
Why are you so tired?
I've been through so much.
Oh, and now I'm the bad guy.
Now I'm the bad guy.
I've been through so much.
But now I'm the bad guy for fucking killing them when they slapped me first.
Oh my god, that's a lot of saves.
Which one's the right one?
Oh, that looks like a pyramid head level.
Guys, can I kill him?
Before I...
Before I fucking go in and shoot pyramid head, can I kill him?
Alright.
You can try?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna go back and shoot that spider lady.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go back.
You guys gonna be smart asses.
I will go back and shoot one of them.
Don't give me a direct answer.
I will go back.
Maria?
There's two of them?
They're my clones.
This is how I'm gonna fake my death.
Just like how I faked Mary's death.
She's smiling.
She's fine.
Did she come back alive?
It's like her fourth death.
I like fucking got used to it.
I'm gonna let the dog out in me.
I'm ready.
Okay, this is...
Why is there two of them?
Oh, shit!
Okay, I gotta reload.
I'm shooting a leg!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, this is not fair.
There's two!
They can throw it down!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God, please.
I'm reloading.
Oh!
Okay, that was my bad.
That was my bad.
That was my bad too!
I'm shooting his legs!
What do you want?
Oh, my God!
How tanky are they?
Holy shit!
They're so tanky!
Guys!
It's so hard to shoot when you have a dog head on you!
Wait.
Wait, he stopped.
What?
What is he doing?
What the fuck?
What happened?
Oh, my God.
I have...
I'm so little.
Oh, my God.
Got an egg.
And another egg.
Got two eggs.
Why did they do that?
Why the fuck did they do that?
Smack that.
La, la, la, la, la.
Okay.
I guess I'll put the eggs in here.
I think they're dead dead.
Extra ammo.
Alright.
That was the pyramid head fight.
Mary?
Flowers?
What, Mary?
You better travel all the way here.
Oh, you're still hot.
You're still so hot.
I guess I'll go to them anyway.
It'd be easier if they just killed me.
But I guess the hospital's making a nice profit off of me.
Why are you still here?
I told you to go.
Are you dead?
Jesus.
Wait.
Please.
Don't leave me alone.
I didn't mean what I said.
Please.
Tell me you'll be okay.
It'll be okay, Mary.
Don't mind the pillow I'm holding.
Oh my god.
Tell me I'm not going there.
Bro.
James.
What the fuck?
Help me.
Okay, I did not mean that.
I did not realize she was going to say that next.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize she was going to say that next.
Okay, now I can run, right?
Can I run now?
I knew it.
It was all because it was too expensive.
It was all about the medical bills.
Alright, in we go.
Oh my god, there's a lot of ammo.
You know things are gonna go crazy.
That is a lot of ammo.
Which way do I go?
This one goes downstairs.
Shape forces the mind.
Oh my god, there's so much ammo.
It's okay.
There's a reason why I have a lot of...
I kept a lot of rifle ammo.
There is a reason.
Right here.
It's time to go.
Here we go.
Up we go.
Oh, rifle is not good?
Well, let me see how much ammo I have on my fucking shotgun.
Guys, I think I messed up a little bit.
I do not have a lot.
I have like...
Like...
15 bullets.
Oh, hey.
A bed.
Mary, why did you put a single bed?
Mary.
Mary, I'm here for the ghost booty call.
Why do you have a single bed?
What do you mean?
She looks just like her.
James, she's right here.
Oh, she's hot again.
She doesn't look like she's sick.
I'm yours.
I'm here for you.
So what if I'm not her?
You're not her?
I can give you what she never could.
Oh my god, really?
Wait, you can do...
Wait, is this Maria?
Oh my god, it's Maria!
Hi.
You can do that thing that she wouldn't do.
I saw M, so I assume that says Mary.
But it was actually Maria.
No?
Huh?
You're part of my head!
What the fuck is that?
Oh shit!
Oh shit, she goes crazy now.
Can I shoot that?
Where is she?
Super freak.
Oh shit, these hurt.
God!
How do I fight this?
Oh, Jesus!
I'm trying to figure out how to dodge this.
Don't fucking finish the rifle.
It's easier, honestly.
Oh shit, oh, she's going full...
Oh no, she's getting on the ground!
No, not the dark!
I don't think I can see!
Oh no, not the dark.
My weakness.
She knows.
She knows I can't see now.
God, please.
I can't see shit.
Do these go away?
Or do I have to shoot it?
Why is she landing?
Oh, you're coming down!
Oh, there you are!
Hey, Maria!
Goodbye, Maria!
I'm gonna shoot these.
They're so annoying.
Hey, Maria!
Oh, I'm back here?
Okay, I'm gonna use my rifle.
Oh shit!
Sorry!
Oh, fuck!
Jesus...
What?!
Bro, her range is actually crazy.
Like, what is this range?
Where'd she go?
Oh god.
Okay.
Dodge.
Alright, rifle only.
Oh, goodbye, I guess.
Time to reload.
Hey, reload!
Don't be rude!
Jesus Christ.
I don't think it helped that, you know.
It definitely does not help that.
I ran out of shotgun ammo!
Oh my god, there we go.
That should be it.
There's no way.
You cannot be alive after that.
Hello?
Maria?
What do I do?
Hey, handsome.
I'm sorry.
Don't be.
I told you.
I wanted the pain to end.
Yeah.
But that's not why I did it.
The truth is...
I hated you.
I wanted you out of the way.
I wanted my life back.
You're so, so beautiful.
Mary.
Why do you look so sad?
It's okay, James.
Here.
What is
this?
It's what you've been looking for.
It's a letter!
Oh my god, Mary.
She wanted me to kill her.
So we can cash out on a life insurance.
Oh my god, she was the love of my life.
I knew this ghost booty call was worth it in the end.
That's true love right there.
The letter's the insurance policy I got.
Wait, did I actually get the good ending?
Best ending, that's a key right?
I knew shooting that guy was not an issue.
I should've came back and shot the spider too.
In my restless dreams, I see that town.
Silent Hill.
You promised you'd take me there again someday.
But you never did.
Well, I'm alone there now.
In our special place.
Waiting for you to come and see me.
But you never do.
So, I wait.
Wrapped in my cocoon of pain and loneliness.
I know, I've done a terrible thing to you.
I wish I could change that, but I can't.
I feel so pathetic and ugly laying here.
Sorry, Gumi sent me pictures of the awards show.
And that is how unfair it is.
The doctor came today.
Told me I could go home for a short stay.
It's not that I'm getting better.
It's just that this could be my last chance.
Even so, I'm glad to be coming home.
I missed you so much.
But I'm afraid, James.
I'm afraid you don't really want me to come home.
Every time you come to see me, I can tell how hard it is on you.
I don't know if you hate me.
I did.
I really hated you.
Maybe I just disgust you.
I'm so sorry.
When I first learned I was gonna die, I couldn't accept it.
I was so angry.
I struck out at everyone I loved.
Especially you.
And that's why I understand if you hate me.
But I want you to know...
I will always love you.
Even though our life together had to end like this...
I still wouldn't trade it for the world.
Well, this letter has gone on too long.
So, I'll say goodbye.
I told the nurse to give this to you after I'm gone.
Which means that as you're reading this, I'm already dead.
But that's okay.
I'm not afraid of it anymore.
I just hope the pain will end soon.
So that you remember me for who I was.
And not what the disease made me.
I want you to go on.
I want you to live.
For yourself.
And for others.
Like you did for me.
So like, he refused to read the letter until now?
You made me happy.
Because like, she died 3 years ago.
So she had the letter...
So he had the letter for 3 years.
Yeah, he couldn't...
Yeah, he couldn't read it.
Oh, she died 3 days ago!
It wasn't really 3... Oh, she was diagnosed 3 years ago!
The 3 years was in my head, just like how I felt like I was playing Silent Hill for 20 years.
Yeah, because like, Laura just turned 8.
No, no, no, no.
She died by natural causes, guys.
That's what we're telling the insurance company.
Guys.
She died by natural causes.
So he didn't want to read the...
He didn't want to read the letter until like now, because he was still accepting the fate that like, you know...
She naturally died with a pillow on top of her head.
Oh my god, we finally did it.
We fucking finally did Silent Hill.
I'm actually so surprised!
We like, did it so fast.
I think like, I was so fucking determined that I just ran straight into everything.
I was like, I can't, I can't, I can't make this a 6 hour thing.
I just like, ran straight and just go...
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships, thank you, thank you.
We did it.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
We finally did it.
Two months after Halloween, we fucking finished Silent Hill 2.
What a journey.
Oh my god, I knew I was gonna get the good end.
You guys were like, no, don't shoot it.
Jesus, it's over.
Bad ending, bad ending.
Look at that chat.
Doesn't matter.
I knew I should have gone back and shot the legs.
I knew it.
I...
You deserve the bad ending.
No joking.
Oh, but the game didn't give it to me.
The game didn't think so.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're finally free of the Silent Hill.
Paladin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you got the other ending, you find out that Mary's corpse is in the back of the car you drove to get.
Is that the bad ending?
The bad ending is that there's a body in my car and I'm gonna let a child...
I'm gonna let a child sit in the car?
What?
Oh, it's the true ending.
Wait, how do you get the true ending?
Am I taking Laura to see it?
Wait.
How do you get the true ending?
You just drive into the lake?
Wait, MrFish, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now it's time for NG+.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But how do you get the fucking body ending though?
Oh, you have to leave James.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I just wasted...
Okay, first off, she died three days ago.
So like, the smell of that would not be the best, to be fair.
Like, I think if Laura gets near the car, she's gonna realize something is very wrong.
Not so fun fact.
It's kinda confirmed that Angela endgamed herself a bit after the ending.
Also, dog ending when?
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can watch the YouTube video of it right now and pretend I got it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there an after credit scene, chat?
Chat, is there an after credit scene?
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
God of War, I guess you wonder where I've been.
Oh yeah, we're going back to Data War.
I was debating like, like, like delaying God of War again for Indiana Jones.
Cause that's coming next week as well.
But then I realized, God of War fans have sort of like, waited for a very long time.
Like some of them have actually become dads now.
So, Doki, no!
That would've been so fucked up.
I would be like, sorry guys, we gotta play Indiana Jones now.
It just came out.
We just keep, we keep like, playing games until like, every time we finish a game, a newer game comes out.
So I'm like, sorry guys, FOMO time.
That would be so fucked up.
Anyway, let's make a poll.
You guys can decide the fate.
By the way, is there, is there an after credit scene?
God of Baiting.
Thank you for the super chat, Kiwi.
Thank you, thank you.
Cosmic, thank you.
Oh yeah, we already said.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
I recommend playing the original.
Phenomenal voice acting and way less padding.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I spike voted this poll.
You are so evil.
Guys, wouldn't it be funny?
Every time we finish a new game.
Another new game keeps coming out.
And then we'll never get the God of War.
There's a new Indiana Jones game coming out next week.
I mean, it's coming out tomorrow actually.
I'm not playing it on like tomorrow.
Like, I know I usually play on launch day.
But like, I'm not gonna play it tomorrow.
How long to beat Indiana Jones game?
Let's see.
It says 12.
12 to 6.
12 hours.
It's not that bad.
12 hours?
Oh my god!
Wait, boy is actually winning!
Wait, is it actually...
Were our reviews out?
Indiana Jones and the Great Circle reviews.
Has reviews been out?
Wait!
Guys!
9 out of 10!
5 out of 5!
Wait, the reviews are actually really fucking good!
It's like 9 out of 10, 9 out of 10, and 5 out of 5.
But, but, but boy.
But, but boy though.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
The number of times I checked the map.
600.
Guys, I was really lost, guys.
I, I was, I was really, really fucking lost, chat.
You don't understand.
Okay, I killed 365, 87, 26, 28.
I got damaged 3,945.
You're getting access to new game plus.
It's okay.
Oh my god, I'm so happy we finally did it.
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's my birthday, super.
I had so much fun watching you play through Silent Hill 2.
Thank you for the super chat.
Brian, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Brian.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Um, honestly, I'm like, I'm so surprised I managed to, like, beat the game.
Um, like, as fast as I thought it, as I thought.
Because I honestly thought it was going to take like five to six hours.
With the rate I was, oh my god.
Whoops, I forgot to put these away.
With the rate I was going on the other playthroughs.
I think I was so determined to finally put this behind me.
I was like, I can't.
In my head, I was just like, I can't keep doing this.
I can't, I can't keep being stuck in Silent Hill.
I gotta, I gotta get through this.
I gotta make it through.
Oh yeah, thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, I'll show you the photo that Goomy sent me.
She's like at the place now.
Um, she's sitting with Sage at him too.
Oh my god, there's like free food and everything.
I couldn't go there.
I was so busy with like everything else.
Um, oh I didn't get, oh yeah, people got interview.
I didn't get interview spot though.
Um, because I said like if I get an interview, just call me.
I see like Nicewig.
Nicewig got an interview.
Look, there's me.
There's me, I'm sitting there.
There's Nicewig right here.
Nicewig is literally right here, getting interviewed right now.
And then look, there's free food.
Oh my god, don't look at the QR code.
Oh my god.
But she got my, basically she gets free food.
Because like, it's my, I gave her my spot.
And then there's Sage at him, taking picture with me.
Um, I gave her like, um, my spot for it.
Uh, because Goomy asked me for it.
And I was like, yeah, that's cool.
Because I'm not going anyway.
Um, because like, there'll be cameras everywhere.
And like, I know like there's some Vtubers that bounce between like Fleshy and, uh, Fleshy and like Vtubing.
But like, um, for me, I like to keep privacy.
I'm more of, I'm a very private person in general.
So for me, like, um, I like to have like, you know, more privacy for it.
Because QT was like telling me how like, oh yeah, the cameras are gonna be everywhere.
And like, there's gonna be cameras panning towards you and stuff like that.
And so like, usually we don't like, we, we, uh, we understand for Vtubers if you don't wanna, if you don't wanna come.
And I was like, yeah.
And like, Goomy asked me about it because she wanted to be my plus one for it.
But I wasn't gonna go anyway.
So then I just gave her my ticket.
Like, I gave her my, um, thing because she wanted to go too.
Um, uh, so like, I was just like, yeah, you can just go as me.
Um, as long as you carry me around.
Uh, I was just like, just carry me around.
I'm cool with that.
Like...
So people know like, like, like, you know, at least I was sort of there.
Um, and she gets free food too.
Also like, I have to travel so much.
Like, cause like, at first, Sejam said that I could, like, Goomy told me that Sejam told her that I could like, hang out at Sejam's place.
And like, use their setup.
And then I'll just go around.
Like, I'll still be like, in LA.
And I'll just go around.
Like, I'll just call in from like, Sejam's place.
And then I could just still be there, technically.
But then I was just like, I don't wanna travel.
Like, I'm gonna be traveling so much.
Um, like, cause I'm gonna be traveling again next week, literally, to Atlanta for the concert.
So like, I'm just like, I don't wanna, I don't wanna travel again.
Like, go to LA, and then come back, and then go to Atlanta.
Cause I'm so, I hate traveling in general.
Um, so I was just like...
Yeah, but then they're like saying like, cause there's an after party.
Um, there's an after party, after the thing.
After the whole Streamer Awards.
There's gonna be like, an after party.
So like, I could technically go to the after party, cause there's no cameras there.
Um, and there's no like, but I just didn't wanna travel at all.
Like, I just, I was just, I just wanna stay at home until I have to fucking go to Atlanta.
Like...
Cause the last time I traveled, I got sick.
So I was just like, I wanna make sure I don't get sick for Atlanta.
So like, that's why I also don't wanna travel right now.
Cause I wanna make sure that I don't get sick again.
Um, I'm not, I don't like traveling a lot too.
I like just staying at home.
Um, yeah, so that's why I was just, like, I was just like, eh, it's fine.
I don't really care that much.
Um, I'm feeling a lot better.
Uh, cough me, I don't cough as much.
But my throat is still like, sore in general.
So, like, I'm getting better.
Obviously, I could get a lot better faster.
But like, if I went to the doctors.
Um, but I'm just toughing it out.
If I'm still sick when I'm in Atlanta, I'm gonna go see a doctor in Atlanta.
That's why, if I'm still sick when I'm in Atlanta, I'll go see a doctor.
But for now, I'm toughing it out right now.
Oh yeah, how's the passport?
Not so great.
I'm gonna go try on Monday to see if I can, uh...
Like, cause like, I read that like, when I throw in an application for my passport.
Um, cause my passport doesn't expire until after.
So like, um, after Atlanta.
So like, it should be fine.
Um, so like, I'm not too worried about that.
It's just that I, I gotta like, make sure that I can use my passport like, in like, upcoming months.
Because I don't, I think I'm gonna have to travel again.
Um, in the beginning of 2025.
So that's like, what I'm really worried about.
Um, so I'm gonna have to get there on Monday.
Like, when the place opens.
Basically, I fucking, oh my god.
I, I hate doing passport stuff.
It's been so long too, since I did passport stuff.
So then I'm just like, filling the forms and everything.
Ah!
Oh yeah, there's so many announcements.
Because like, oh wait.
Oh yeah, here, Gumi's holding me.
Right here.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
Oh yeah, by the way, like.
They're like, oh yeah, put your name in.
So when we check your ID.
Like, uh, we know that you're you.
And then I just put her name on it.
Cause, haha, she's technically Doki Bird right now.
See, that's me.
I'm there.
Look, I'm at the Streamer Awards, everybody.
That's me.
Oh my god!
Um, oh wait, Seija fucking tweeted it.
Seija actually tweeted it too.
Yeah, I'm her date.
Guys.
Jealous.
Should've been me.
Um, alright, let's grab the Super Chats right now.
Um.
It's like, okay, but to be fair, I'm like streaming.
I'm not actually there there.
It's more like when you bring a picture of like.
It's like when you bring like those like.
What's it called?
Like when you go to prom.
And you bring like.
Like a fucking.
Like, you know like those prom dates thing.
Where you, where like girls or guys.
Or bring in like some form of like.
Plushie or like.
And then tape like the picture.
Of like their oshi or whatever.
Or oshi or like.
Favorite star or celebrity.
And stuff like that.
Yeah, cut out.
It's like me as a cut out.
Oh, I could've just asked her to bring a cut out version of me.
And then.
But like I'm not actually there.
Wait, you never heard of that?
Like I remember like seeing like prom photos.
Of like, like teenagers.
Who don't have a date.
Like who have like.
Who are like super obsessed with celebrities.
And they like print out a picture of their face.
And then like paste it on like some.
Something.
And then be like this is my date.
Like.
Like that's how I see it right now.
Get a picture of it.
Print it out and then paste it in.
Like that's my date right there.
Taylor Lautner.
Oh
yeah, the ones with Diana Vito.
We have seen those, yeah.
Okay, wait.
I'll show you guys.
This one.
This person brought Danny DeVito.
This is basically how I see it.
How I see it for Gumi.
Um.
This is what it looks like.
This girl brought Danny DeVito to prom.
That's me and Gumi.
That's.
That's basically me and Gumi.
That's me right now.
That's how I see it.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, my mouse is freaking out right now.
Woah!
Give me a second.
My mouse is freaking out.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait, what happened to my tab?
It like closed like my entire window.
I might need to buy a new mouse.
Cause like.
It like freaked out.
Cause it kept like left clicking by itself.
On the right side.
So like I think there's something wrong with like the.
Um.
The connection or something.
Cause I have, mine's wireless.
There's something wrong with the wireless stuff.
Cause it does that sometimes.
Every like.
It does that like sometimes but it doesn't do it frequently.
So maybe like a month or two.
Or maybe the battery is low.
I didn't charge it in a while.
Let me check.
Let me check the battery.
No, it's 47%.
I think my.
It's just fucking freaking.
It's just getting old.
Um.
But yeah, I hope she has fun.
I hope she has fun at the streamer awards.
I think that's the only sad thing.
About being a Vtuber.
Is that obviously you miss out on like.
A lot of these like physical events and stuff.
Because like I don't.
I don't like.
I'm like a really private person.
So like I don't want people to know.
Where I live.
What I look like.
Outside of the skin suit and stuff.
So like I don't want people to spot me.
And be like.
That's Doki Bird.
So I'm a very private person when it comes to that.
And I don't like having.
Cause I've like denied.
I remember like Respawn has like.
Asked me so many times.
To like visit their facilities.
And like visit.
Visit their offices.
But like it would also have like.
There would be other content creators too.
So like I always get like.
Super paranoid cause I was like.
I don't really want to be like filmed or like.
I don't want pictures of me.
With other content creators.
Especially content creators that I don't know in general.
I'll be like oh I don't really know who they are.
So like I feel a little.
I feel a little like weird.
About it because I don't want these people.
Who I don't really know what I look like.
Like I don't want them to see me.
Without my skin suit.
I actually got messaged.
By like.
Cause I got my YouTube partner manager.
Like send me a message.
And they were like.
Oh my god we're having a meet up.
With all the other YouTubers.
All the other YouTubers in your city.
Would you like to like.
Do you want to come?
There's going to be free food.
And you get to network with other YouTubers.
I was like I don't know.
I don't really.
I'm sorry.
I don't really want them to know.
That's weird.
I don't know for me.
I don't want them to know.
I live here.
They know what I like.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
she's not even a YouTuber either.
And they're like.
You can pretend.
To be like her manager.
You know.
Like Doki birds manager.
As her representative.
Oh man.
That's so awkward.
That the manager sounds.
Exactly like her.
I was just like.
I didn't say that but.
In my head.
I was like, how the fuck is that supposed to work?
I have to talk to people that can sound exactly like me.
I was like, no, it's alright.
No, I don't need to go.
I don't really care that much, to be fair.
But yeah, I mean, it would've been nice to be able to go to the streamer awards just for the sake of like, you know, You know, hanging out and like, you know, it's like, it looks like a really cool event.
I think like, getting, being able to go to the streamer awards seems to be like, a really cool, um...
A really cool opportunity in general.
So it's like, uh...
So it's more so of like, I do, I feel a bit sad that I couldn't like, go there, um...
Because of the cameras and stuff and everything will be streamed and everything.
But it's like, the sacrifices I have to make, you know.
The sacrifices I have to make to keep my privacy, um...
But yeah, uh, anyway.
Super chat reading time!
I don't know if I can get through all of it, because I want to rest my voice, because I have some recording stuff to do after.
So I'm gonna do like, five super chats.
Uh, I hope that's okay.
Um...
Mike!
Doki beat Solid Hill 2 remake.
Yippee!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rosie!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You treat your wife well, Doki.
Uh, Gavrange!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki Bird, more like Dochi Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, okay, so God of War.
We're going back to God of War, guys.
We're gonna go back.
He's, he's won.
Indiana Jones fans, I'm sorry.
No FOMO for you.
For once, there's no more, there's no FOMO for you, Indiana Jones fans.
You gotta wait.
You gotta fucking wait.
Um, Wristwatch!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uphold democracy or succumb to FOMO.
Choose, Doki!
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Funilus!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
333 times you try to open locked doors.
Hey, they could be open, chat!
I mean, maybe, maybe it'll be open.
You don't know that.
They might be like, huh, JK, it's actually unlocked now.
But thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, all right, last super chat.
Last super chat of the day.
Niel!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on finally finishing Silent Hill 2.
This should be like, guys, this should be a celebration.
It took me eight fucking parts to finish this game, chat.
Like, I- I- almost every stream, I did two to three hours every time I streamed.
Because my heart was just- I couldn't take it.
It was too much.
It was too fucking much, guys.
But we did it, chat.
Out of eight streams.
Eight streams, two months.
Um, many dragoons getting married, many dragoons finding love, many dragoons having children.
Um, we fucking did it.
Now your kids can watch the entire, uh, playthrough of Silent Hill 2.
And they don't have to, like, wait until they also have kids until it's over.
Uh, but thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, on the topic- oh yeah, Niel.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
On the topic of ending, there's no true ending.
It is confirmed by the original dev that every ending is canon.
Yes, including the dog one.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, technically, I could see, like, them find- him finding a bod- him having the body in the back of his trunk.
And also, like, the good ending with the Laura thing.
Like, they are- they can both happen at the same ti- like, they can both be true.
Because, like, she- the body's not going anywhere.
It's still in the back of his trunk.
Uh, what I'm most surprised by is that how the fuck did she- he sneak the body into his car from all the nurses?
Wait, she's not in the trunk, she's in the backseat?
For three days?
Wait, what?
I thought when you said, like, in the tru- oh, okay.
Oh, so she's basically taking her to see- oh, James is a little weird.
That's- you know what, that's my line.
All the other stuff, like, I understand.
Like, medical bills are very hard to pay off.
Like, I understand medical debt and everything, but, like, him putting her in the back of the- in the backseat and then taking Laura to see her?
That's a little weird.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, that's a bit freaky.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I can't believe we did it, guys.
We're all here to see me finish Silent Hill 2.
I have a lot of recordings to do after this, so I'm gonna rest my voice, rest my throat, and finish some recordings.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and if you stood up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
I forgot to say, if you guys want to check out Hyatt Collection, check it out.
If you want to support me and Hyatt, I have custom PCKs and keycaps there.
Whoa!
My last chill of the day.
Bye!